[Music]
a ten-year-old boy
fighting for his life tonight after
police say he was hit by a car
last week that crash happened about 6 30
friday night near
cadence park not too far from lake mead
parkway and center street
the little boy is now at umc orca mana
is there live tonight after speaking
exclusively to his family
marco well denise 10 year
10 year old trusarion jackson is in
critical condition
here at umc his family tells me they're
doing their best to stay positive
as police continue their investigation
he ain't just bouncing back but i know
that he will because he always do
fighting back tears laconia jackson is
holding on to hope
she says her ten-year-old son true
zerion was biking with a group of
friends friday night leaving cadence
park in henderson
when he was hit by a truck at lake mead
parkway and center street he's now in
critical condition at umc
i try to stay strong around him because
he can't hear me
you know i'm just trying to keep him
comfort and let him know that i'm here
by his side
and i'm waiting for him to come up out
of this true zerion is still on an
oxygen tube but lakanya says he's now
off sedation and doing better we're
waiting for him to
react more on his arm henderson police
say preliminary details show speed and
impairment are not believed to be
factors in the crash
and parents at cadence park tell us
drivers don't usually speed in the area
they actually stop and they stop for us
totally and then they slow down most of
the time every time i've been on that
street it's pretty
pretty tame lacanya praised truezerion
continues to make progress
and she has a message for her son you're
very strong
you have plenty of support out here for
you
and i love you baby
henderson police say the investigation
into the crash is still
active but they are not releasing any
more details at this time
reporting live from unc tonight orca
mana 8 news now